.
IT'S CALLE "E TAL OF KYLE.
YOU CAN GET ANXCLUSIVEREVI
IN A MENT.
GOOD EVENINGND WCOME TO
TUER CARLSON TONHT.
RE'S A QUESTIO
AT HAPPENS WHE YOU CRUSH
ENRE SECTORS OF YOUR OWN
ONOMY FOR NEAY TWO YEARS AND
THENOOMPENSATE FOROUR
CRIME YOU DECEO INJECT
TRILLIONS OF DOARS  FRESHLY
INTED CA INTO THE SYSTEM.
AT HAPPENS IF YOU  THAT?
WE DON'T KW WT HAPPENS WN
YOU DO THAT BAUSE NO ONE IN
HISTORY HAS ER BEEN STUPIDENOUG.
IT'S GOING TO BEEARS BEFORE H
RELY UNDERSTAND THE
CONSEQUENCESF A TS, OUR
GORNMENTS OR RECESS
COROVIRUS POLICY.
IN T MEANTIME WEAN S WITH
TOL CONFINCE THAT THE
AMERICCONOMY IS GETNG VERY
WEIRD.
NOT ALL OFT.
SOME OF WHATE ARE SEEING ISN
WEIRIN THE SLIGHTE.
IT W ENTIRELY PRECTABLE.
YOU CATERILLNS OF U.S.
DOLLARS OUT  NOTHING, U.S.
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO BE WORTH
LESS.
MUCH LESS.
THIS IS CALLED INFLATION.
WERE SFERINGHROUGH IT
GHT NOW
FLATN VERY SIMPLYS A
RESULT OF TOO MUCH MONEY IN TH
STEM.
IF YOU HE TOO MUCHOMETHING,ITS L
SUPPND DEMAND, REMEM
THIS IS AT'SAUSING THE RIS
IN REAL ESTE PRICES AND
TCOIN AND OTH ASSETS
VESTS WANT TO WHE THEY NOLOER T.
WH CAN YOU AFFORD AOUSE
RIGHT NOW
SIMPLE.
WASHINGTON PRINTEDOO MUCHMONEY.
NO ONEHOULD BE SURPRISED BTHIS.
THE CYE IS AS OLD AS MONEY
ITSE.
POLITIL LEADERS DEV THE
CURRCY FOR SHORT-TERM GA.
IN THE END, THI LEADSO
LONG-TERM COLLAPSE.
DEBASING T COINA, THAT'
WH THEY USE IT TO CALL I
BY THE MIDDL OF THEHIRD
SURGERY, T ROME IO THE AREA,
E SILVER COIN WAS 2% SILVE.
THENTIRE ROMAN EIRE BLEW UP
IN THE BARBAANSOOK OVER.IT WASNO
DID THIS.
EVERGOVERNMENT DEVALUES S
CURRENT SOME POINT
THEY DOT BAUSE OF THE
IRRESIIBLE.
YO CAN NOT DO IT.
IF YOUO IT YOU GET FREE MON
N'T HAVE TO RAISE TES.
SEEMS KE A GOOD IDEA BUTN
THE E EVE GOVERENT PAYSTHE PCE .
MORE PRECISE ITS CITIZENS DO.
THE CURNT INFLATION, HORRIE
AS IT IS, HARYNEXCED
YOUAVE TO BE A FED CHAIRMAN
NOT TO HAVEEEN ITOMING.
WHAT'S CONFUSING AS HELLS OUR
LAR MAET.
THE UNDERPAYMENT RATE I HIGR
AN IT W BEFORE COV.
NOT A TON BUT SOM
THAT MNS FEWER PEOPLE HAV
JOBS THAT DID TEARSGO.
LABOR FORC PTICIPATION,
SLHTLYIFFERENT MEASUMENT,
ITS WAY DOWN AN THA MEANS YOUR
PEOP ARE WORKING OR EVEN
OKING FOR JOB
SO THAT' THE PICTURE O ONE
SIDE O THE LAB MARKET.
AN YET, THIS THE TRULY
BIZARRE PART, WE ASILTANEOUSLY A
SERIS LABOR SRTAGE.
WE HAVE A SRTAGE OFABOR AND
NEGLECT  LAB SIMULTANESLY.
IN SE PLES,USINESSES HE
UTOWN BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
FIND EMPLOYE, AS YOU WEL KNOW
IF YOU LIVEERE.
SO AGAINT THE VERY SAMEMOMENT, Y
WORKS ANDLSO T FEW
RKERS.
THAT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
HOW CAN THAT PSIBLYE
PPENING?
AND AGAIN, WERE GOING TO BE
HONEST ANDELLOU WE ARE NOT
ENTIRELY SUREOW IT'SHAENING.
NO ONE IS ENTIRELY SURE.
BUT WE CAN TELL YOU IS
DEFINITELY N NATURAL.
IS IS NOTOW MKETS ARE
PPOSED TO WORK.
THIS IS  A GOOD SIGN.
IF YOU ARE RNING THEOUNTRY
AND YOU ULD BE RESPONSIBLE
PE, YOU'D BE CCERNED ABOUT
A TREND LIKE TS BUT THE
LEADERS DOT SEEM ESPECIAY
CONCERNED
A PFESSOR OF ECOMICST
MIIGAN STATE UNIRSITY, COOK
HAS ADVISED JOE BIDEN'SCONOMIC
SSIB.
E IS CONDEREDHOO-IN FORA PLUMB E
BOAR
LI COOK WILL BE ONE O THE
PEOPLE IN ARGEITH FIXING THE
ME.
W IS SHE GOI TOO?
THE EAR SES AREOT
PECIALLY PROMING.
NOTONG AGO COOKND OTH
FALTY MEMBERS AT
MICHIG STATE GOT AN EIL FROM
THR SCHOOL.
"ALL RESIDENTIALININ HALLS
COULD USE YR HELP."IT TURNS OUTF
REN'T SHOWING UP TO WORK.PARTLYC
POLICIES THAT TH WEIT HAS HAD
ENACTED ON T ADVE OF LISA
COOK
AS A RULT OF THAT THE
CAFEAS DESPERATE NEEDED
CULTTO PITCH IN A HELP TO
FEED PEOPLE.
AND YETS F AS WE KNOW, LA
COOK DESPI HER PERFELY
SUIT LAST NAME,ID NOT HP.
SHE STAYED ME
IN CE YOU THINKE ARE SINGGOING ,
A LOT OFEOPLE ARE SYING HOME
THESE DAYS.
THEY'RE NO PITCHIN IN.THE NUMB E
JOBS HAS DROPPED B NRLY
5 MILLIOPEOPLE SINCE FEBARY
OF LAST YEAR.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE AORDING
TO THE GOVNMENT ASSEMENT IS
LOOKING FOR A NEW J.
WHY?
LOTSF REASONS.
SOME OF THEM HAV RETED.OTHERS HK
IT'S DIFFICULT FORHE
GOVERNNT TO KP TRACK OF.
NOT ALWAYS A BAD THING.
IFOU HAVEEFT ALRUSHING
B AT CITIBAN TO TEN AN
ORNIC PLE ORCHARD, IS KIND
OF HARD TO SEE H THA IS AET
LOSS FOR SOCIETY
WEHOULD BE CELEBRATING
GOODOR YOU.
THPROBLEM IS WITH ALTHE
REST.
SOME LARGE PCENTAGE OF
ABLE-BODIEAMERICANS HAVE JUST
DECIDE TOTOP WORKINGT ALL.
NOW IN THE LONGUN, THIS IS A
BIG CHANGE
IT'S NOT GOOFOR THE NATIOL
CHARTER, FOR EXAMPLE.
HEALTHY SOCIETS VALUE WORK.
EY BELIEVE ITONFERS DIGNI
AN MEANING.
BUT IN THE SHORT TER AS AN
ECONOMIC MATTER, IT'KILLG
ALL BUSINESS.
SEEKER THERES A DRIVEORGE IN THD
IT'S NOT JT HITTING
TRANSPORTING GOO.
SCHOOLUS DRIVERS A IN SHORT
SUPPLY TOO>> AND THE MAGERORKS E
REGISTER.
TO COV SHORT STAFFING, FACT
LIFE IN SO MA BINESSES.
>> SOME WALGREE PHARMACY
DRIVTHRU IS LIKEHISNEN
GRN BA I'VE BEEN BLOCKEDFF
RECENTLY.
SIGNS POS ON E WINDOWAY
THEY DON HAVE EUGH STA.
CERTAIN JOBECTO LIKE
RETAIL, RESTRANTS AND
HOSPITALITY ARE UNDSTAFD.
NO MATTER HOW YOU SLIC I
>> THE GERNMENT HAS
INNTIVIZED PEOPLNO TO WOR
IT'S RLLY TOUGH TO GET
PEOPLE TO WORK AND OEHEY ARE
HE, TOTAND FOR MORE AN SIX
MOHS.
>>ucker: WHY IS THI
HAPPENINGUESTION AGAIN, T
SIGNOF IT ARE EVERYWHERE.
ERE IS NO ROOM SERCE AND
YOUR HOTEL, IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T
NOTICED AN THAT IS THE LEAST OF
IT.ONE OFHE REASONS THIS I
PPENING IS BECSE GOVERNMENT
PUT OUTOME REALLY DTRUCTIVEPOLIS
HE IS BILL KANE TO EXPIN.
>> THIS IS KHY.
THISS THEIGNOU HAD U
FRONT ANWE CAME IN.
WE ARE SRT STAFFED.
EASE BE PATIEN WITH THE STAFF
WHDID SHOW UP.NO ONE WANTS T WO.
TH WOULD RATHER DWN
PLOYMENT.
>> THAS TRUE,HAT SO TRUI'M SOIR.
QUIT GIVING ALL THIS
EMPLOYMENT.
THEY A GETTING UNEMPLOENT.
TU
WHYORK.
EY ME A LOT OF MON.
EY ARE QUITTINJUST SO TY
CAN GET ON ELOYMT.
STL ONE SO Y NEV HEAR
ANYBODY ON  SAY THATUT IF YOU'RE
AROUND PEOPLE WITH WT WE
USED TCALL WORKING-CLASS
JOBS YOU HEAR ITLL T
TIME.
YOU HEAR IT  LOT.
PEOPLERE MAD ABOUT IT.
ATHE INTERNATIONAL HOUSEF
PANCAK IN WASILLA,LASKA,
IT'S NOT ALWAYS POSSIE TO GET
PIGS IN A BLAET.
RE'S THE MESSAGE.
DUEO THE FACT THAT BIDEN GAVOUTD
NODY WANTS TOORK ANYMORE WE
ARE FORCED TO RUCE R HOURS
DURING THEEEK.
SO THERE IS SOME TRUTH IN THIS.
AT TIM OVER T PAST TWO
YEARS, SE PELEERE MAKIN
MUCHORE IN GOVERNMT
UNEMPLMENTENEFITS AND TY
D BEEN MAKG I THEOBS THATTHEY L.
ONE ANYSISOUND THAT THANKS
THE SO-CALLED TEARS A,
REAURANT WORKERS NEARLDOUBLEDHEP
WHHEY BECAME UNPLOYED.
TH GERNMENT W LITERALLY
MAKING IT RE LUCRATI FOR
PEOPLE NOT TO RK AND STAAT
HOME.
THAT'S THE DEFINITIO OFINSANITYT
WRECK OUR ECONOMY I CLOSE IHOP,
THERE  AN OBVIOUS MORAL COST,
WHAT IS THE MESSAGEHE
GOVEMENT IS ING?
THMESSES SENDING THA YOU
WOULD HAVE TO BE ANDIOTORK.
YOU'VEOT TO WONDERHATAMAGE
THAT MESSAGEASONEO THE
COUNY'S TITUDES ABOUT RK.
HE IS ONE MEASURE OF THE
DAMA POTENTIALLY
SUPPLEMENTAL UNEMPYMEN
BEFITS ENDED THI FALL.
THEY WE SOLEARLY NUTS.
YET A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'TO
CK TO WORK.
IN FACEVEN MOR AMERICANS QUITTHS
ARE INKING ABOUT QUITTIN
RIGHNOW.
AGN, THIS ISN'T ALL BAD.
IT'S COMPLEX A WE WANT TO BE
HOST.
SOMEOBS AREN'T WTHAVING
PEER WE WISH PPLE WOULD QUIT.
IT WOULD GRE TO SEE A MASS
ODUS OF DIVERSY OFFICER.
THEY CAN DO TIL WORK.
WE HOPE TY WILL.
AND WE MUSTE HONEST,EOPLE
WHO DO WANT TOORK,T'S A
SHRINKG NUMBER.THERE'S GOOD WS .
WAGES ARE UP DMATILLY.
PRETTYLEAR AT THE BOTTO
END.
SOME FAST FOODORKERS A
MAKING 18 CKS  HOUR PLUS
SIGNIN BONUSES AND THAT SEEMS
LIKE SETHING TO CELEBRATE BUT
OF COURSE NONE IN WASHINGT
ISELEBRATING.
IT'S AICTORY FOR AMERICANS
DON'TAVE COLLEGE DEGREESND
THAT A DEFEAT FOR EM SO IN
WAINGTON THEY ARTHINKING OF
WA TO USE MASS INTEGTION TO
SHAFT WORKERS OUOF TIR
INS.
IMMIGRANTS COULD FIX U.S. LABOR
SHORTAGE RD AECENT HEADLINE
THE HEAD  DOMINO'S PIZZ
GREASE.
HE WOULD LIK TO PAY H
EMPLEES LESSON HEOULD LE
TO U NEW IMPORTED FORGN
WORKERS.
HOW DOESHE WTE HOUSE FEEL?
BIDEN IS O BOA.
HE WAN DEMRATICOTERS FROM
FOIGNOUNTRIES.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING ATS THE
PERFECTLIGNMENT OF MAGNANT
MOTIS.
PECT THE BORDE TO STAY OPEN.WHEI
INKI ABOUT AND WHA WE
SHOULD ALL BE INKI ABOUT ISWHY E
FIRST PLACE.
WHARE FEW PEOPLE CHOOSING T
WORK
ANHAVE BEEN FOR A LON TIME BY
THE WAY.
THIS IS NOT AEW TND.
OUR LABOR MARTS HAVE BEEN
GETTING SICK FORENERATIONS.
THISS ONE MSURE.
THIS SWS THE LABOR FORCE
PARTIPATION RATE OAMERICAN
N.
WHATO YOUOTICE, THE LIN
GOES STRAIGHDOWN.
THIS IS THE LAR FORCE
PARTICIPATION RATE  WOM IN
AMERICA.THAT LINE MOV IN THE OPE
DIRECTION.
AS YOU C TL FOR 7 Y
WE'VEEEN LOSING MENN THE
WORKFORCE
MANY CALLHIS PROGRESS ON THE
ASMPTION THAT ANYTHING IS BAD
AND DEGRANG FOREN MUST BEGOOD FT
PROGRESS.IT'S A PBLEM.
THVERAGE MANEFINES HIMSELF
BY HISOB.
MEN AND WOM A VERY
FFERENT, EXTREMELY DFERE.
CIETY IS BUILT ONHEIR
DIERENCES.
EVERSOCIY IS IN E TNG
ABT MEN AS THEY KIND OF NE
TO WK.
THEY TEN TO FALL APA WN
EY ARE UNEMPLOYED.NOT ALLF THEMF
TH DO TTE SHOULD BE
WORRD ONLY SEE TNDS LIKE
TH.
BUT LEARS AREN'T WRIED.
HEEDSS OF THE CONSEQUENCES,
THEY U COVID TO ACCELERATE THE
TREN
HERE'SNE EXAMPLE.
O IS HURT MT BY VACNE
MANDATES?
OF THE GROUP LST LIKEL TO GET
VACCINATED, WORKINGLASS MEN.
WHAT PERNTAGE OF"NEW YORTIMES" E
OBEYEDOE BEN H BEEN
INCTEDITH T VACCINE?
PROBABLY AROD00%.AMONG MEN WHOOS
TH NUMR IS CLOSER TO 10%.
A MASSIVE DIFFERENCE.
MASSIVE DISPARAT EFFT.
LIKE A LOT IN AMERIN LIFE,
THE'S ACTUALLY ALASS WAR IN
PROGRE HER
JUST BENTH THE SURFACE.WHEN YOUT
TAKING AN JECTION BY THE WAY
DOESN'T WK, YOU'RE NOT HURTITHE.
YOU'RE HURTI BLUE-COLLAR
PELE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY TY AREOINGIT.
EITHER WAY HE IS THEORE.
THE INCENTIVESHAT WE HAVE
CONSTRUCTEDN THIS COUNTRY OVER
A NGERIOD OF TIME.
ACCELERATING RENTLY HAVE A
VERY SPECIC EFFECT.THOSE POLICIO
DOT WANT A JOB AND THEYUNISH
PEOP WHO DO WAN A JOB.
AT THEY DO IS THE DEGRADE
RK.
TH STRIP IT O ITS INHERT
ANING AND THAT' A PROEM IN
A COUNTRY THAT'SUNNING OUTF
THGS THAAV INHENTMEING.
TH AREELNG YOU THA YOUR
LIGI MEANS NOTHI, YOUR
PATRTIEANS NOTHING, YR
FAMILY MEA NOTNG.
NOTHEY ARE TELNG Y YR
WORK MNS NOTHING.
WHAT DOES MEAN ANYTHIN ON HOWLON